The next issue we're going to explore is basically purely selling my own views and opinions,
but the next issue we're going to explore is the question,
Can random testing inspire confidence?
And so what I said earlier in this course is the purpose of testing is to maximize
the number of bugs found per amount of effort spent testing,
and so that's really what testing is all about.
On the other hand, when we start to do a better and better job testing
especially using random testing, we start to get tempted to use those results
as justification to believe that we're creating good software.
What I want to talk about now is, is that ever justified, is that an inference that we can make?
What I think I can give is sort of a highly qualified yes answer to this question.
Let's go through the qualifications.
If we have an API that we understand really well and we have a relatively small piece of code
For example we're doing unit testing of a data structure like a balanced tree
and we have a strong and well-chosen collection of assertion embedded in that code
and we have a mature, well-tuned random tester, and we've measured coverage
and shown that coverage is good then at least in some cases, I think we can conclude
that the software is pretty good.
What I mean basically by this is that I could or any of you could take the splay tree
that we looked at for the queue or red ??? or something.
Do all of these things and develop a reasonably high degree of confidence as described.
If any of these conditions isn't met, I would strongly doubt
whether random testing can inspire confidence.
If you don't have a small code, let's say that instead of small code
we have would be acrobat reader, there's no way, even if we have all these other things
that we could possibly get any confidence in the quality of that software using random testing.
For example, if we don't have a small code, if we have for example adobe acrobat reader
then even all of these other things were true,
there is no way that random testing would inspire the confidence in the quality of the product.
The thing we should keep in mind is since these conditions for inspiring confidence
are quite restrictive, we never just do random testing.
We always use it to augment other testing methods that might be even better
at showing up some of the weakness of random testing.